Hi, I’m Carrie Anne, and welcome to CrashCourse
Computer Science!
Over the past two episodes, we got our first
taste of programming in a high-level language,
like Python or Java.
We talked about different types of programming
language statements – like assignments,
ifs, and loops – as well as putting statements
into functions that perform a computation,
like calculating an exponent.
Importantly, the function we wrote to calculate
exponents is only one possible solution.
There are other ways to write this function
– using different statements in different
orders – that achieve exactly the same numerical
result.
The difference between them is the algorithm,
that is the specific steps used to complete
the computation.
Some algorithms are better than others even
if they produce equal results.
Generally, the fewer steps it takes to compute,
the better it is, though sometimes we care
about other factors, like how much memory
it uses.
The term algorithm comes from Persian polymath
Muḥammad ibn Mūsā al-Khwārizmī who was
one of the fathers of algebra more than a
millennium ago.
The crafting of efficient algorithms – a
problem that existed long before modern computers
– led to a whole science surrounding computation,
which evolved into the modern discipline of…
you guessed it!
Computer Science!
INTRO
One of the most storied algorithmic problems
in all of computer science is sorting… as
in sorting names or sorting numbers.
Computers sort all the time.
Looking for the cheapest airfare, arranging
your email by most recently sent, or scrolling
your contacts by last name -- those all require
sorting.
You might think “sorting isn’t so tough…
how many algorithms can there possibly be?”
The answer is: a lot.
Computer Scientists have spent decades inventing
algorithms for sorting, with cool names like
Bubble Sort and Spaghetti Sort.
Let’s try sorting!
Imagine we have a set of airfare prices to
Indianapolis.
We’ll talk about how data like this is represented
in memory next week, but for now, a series
of items like this is called an array.
Let’s take a look at these numbers to help
see how we might sort this programmatically.
We’ll start with a simple algorithm.
First, let’s scan down the array to find
the smallest number.
Starting at the top with 307.
It’s the only number we’ve seen, so it’s
also the smallest.
The next is 239, that’s smaller than 307,
so it becomes our new smallest number.
Next is 214, our new smallest number.
250 is not, neither is 384, 299, 223 or 312.
So we’ve finished scanning all numbers,
and 214 is the smallest.
To put this into ascending order, we swap
214 with the number in the top location.
Great.
We sorted one number!
Now we repeat the same procedure, but instead
of starting at the top, we can start one spot
below.
First we see 239, which we save as our new
smallest number.
Scanning the rest of the array, we find 223
is the next smallest, so we swap this with
the number in the second spot.
Now we repeat again, starting from the third
number down.
This time, we swap 239 with 307.
This process continues until we get to the
very last number, and voila, the array is
sorted and you’re ready to book that flight
to Indianapolis!
The process we just walked through is one
way – or one algorithm – for sorting an
array.
It’s called Selection Sort -- and it’s
pretty basic.
Here’s the pseudo-code.
This function can be used to sort 8, 80, or
80 million numbers - and once you've written
the function, you can use it over and over
again.
With this sort algorithm, we loop through
each position in the array, from top to bottom,
and then for each of those positions, we have
to loop through the array to find the smallest
number to swap.
You can see this in the code, where one FOR
loop is nested inside of another FOR loop.
This means, very roughly, that if we want
to sort N items, we have to loop N times,
inside of which, we loop N times, for a grand
total of roughly N times N loops...
Or N squared.
This relationship of input size to the number
of steps the algorithm takes to run characterizes
the complexity of the Selection Sort algorithm.
It gives you an approximation of how fast,
or slow, an algorithm is going to be.
Computer Scientists write this order of growth
in something known as – no joke – “big
O notation”.
N squared is not particularly efficient.
Our example array had n = 8 items, and 8 squared
is 64.
If we increase the size of our array from
8 items to 80, the running time is now 80
squared, which is 6,400.
So although our array only grew by 10 times
- from 8 to 80 – the running time increased
by 100 times – from 64 to 6,400!
This effect magnifies as the array gets larger.
That’s a big problem for a company like
Google, which has to sort arrays with millions
or billions of entries.
So, you might ask, as a burgeoning computer scientist, is there a more efficient sorting algorithm?
Let’s go back to our old, unsorted array
and try a different algorithm, merge sort.
The first thing merge sort does is check if
the size of the array is greater than 1.
If it is, it splits the array into two halves.
Since our array is size 8, it gets split into
two arrays of size 4.
These are still bigger than size 1, so they
get split again, into arrays of size 2, and
finally they split into 8 arrays with 1 item
in each.
Now we are ready to merge, which is how “merge
sort” gets its name.
Starting with the first two arrays, we read
the first – and only – value in them,
in this case, 307 and 239.
239 is smaller, so we take that value first.
The only number left is 307, so we put that
value second.
We’ve successfully merged two arrays.
We now repeat this process for the remaining
pairs, putting them each in sorted order.
Then the merge process repeats.
Again, we take the first two arrays, and we
compare the first numbers in them.
This time its 239 and 214.
214 is lowest, so we take that number first.
Now we look again at the first two numbers
in both arrays: 239 and 250.
239 is lower, so we take that number next.
Now we look at the next two numbers: 307 and
250.
250 is lower, so we take that.
Finally, we’re left with just 307, so that
gets added last.
In every case, we start with two arrays, each
individually sorted, and merge them into a
larger sorted array.
We repeat the exact same merging process for
the two remaining arrays of size two.
Now we have two sorted arrays of size 4.
Just as before, we merge, comparing the first
two numbers in each array, and taking the
lowest.
We repeat this until all the numbers are merged,
and then our array is fully sorted again!
The bad news is: no matter how many times
we sort these, you’re still going to have
to pay $214 to get to Indianapolis.
Anyway, the “Big O” computational complexity
of merge sort is N times the Log of N.
The N comes from the number of times we need
to compare and merge items, which is directly
proportional to the number of items in the
array.
The Log N comes from the number of merge steps.
In our example, we broke our array of 8 items
into 4, then 2, and finally 1.
That’s 3 splits.
Splitting in half repeatedly like this has
a logarithmic relationship with the number
of items - trust me!
Log base 2 of 8 equals 3 splits.
If we double the size of our array to 16 – that's
twice as many items to sort – it only increases
the number of split steps by 1 since log base
2 of 16 equals 4.
Even if we increase the size of the array
more than a thousand times, from 8 items to
8000 items, the number of split steps stays
pretty low.
Log base 2 of 8000 is roughly 13.
That's more, but not much more than 3 -- about
four times larger – and yet we’re sorting
a lot more numbers.
For this reason, merge sort is much more efficient
than selection sort.
And now I can put my ceramic cat collection
in name order MUCH faster!
There are literally dozens of sorting algorithms
we could review, but instead, I want to move
on to my other favorite category of classic
algorithmic problems: graph search!
A graph is a network of nodes connected by
lines.
You can think of it like a map, with cities
and roads connecting them.
Routes between these cities take different
amounts of time.
We can label each line with what is called
a cost or weight.
In this case, it’s weeks of travel.
Now let’s say we want to find the fastest
route for an army at Highgarden to reach the
castle at Winterfell.
The simplest approach would just be to try
every single path exhaustively and calculate
the total cost of each.
That’s a brute force approach.
We could have used a brute force approach
in sorting, by systematically trying every
permutation of the array to check if it’s
sorted.
This would have an N factorial complexity
- that is the number of nodes, times one less,
times one less than that, and so on until
1.
Which is way worse than even N squared.
But, we can be way more clever!
The classic algorithmic solution to this graph
problem was invented by one of the greatest
minds in computer science practice and theory,
Edsger Dijkstra, so it’s appropriately named
Dijkstra's algorithm.
We start in Highgarden with a cost of 0, which
we mark inside the node.
For now, we mark all other cities with question
marks - we don’t know the cost of getting
to them yet.
Dijkstra's algorithm always starts with the
node with lowest cost.
In this case, it only knows about one node,
Highgarden, so it starts there.
It follows all paths from that node to all
connecting nodes that are one step away, and
records the cost to get to each of them.
That completes one round of the algorithm.
We haven’t encountered Winterfell yet, so
we loop and run Dijkstra's algorithm again.
With Highgarden already checked, the next
lowest cost node is King's Landing.
Just as before, we follow every unvisited
line to any connecting cities.
The line to The Trident has a cost of 5.
However, we want to keep a running cost from
Highgarden, so the total cost of getting to
The Trident is 8 plus 5, which is 13 weeks.
Now we follow the offroad path to Riverrun,
which has a high cost of 25, for a total of 33.
But we can see inside of Riverrun that we’ve
already found a path with a lower cost of
just 10.
So we disregard our new path, and stick with
the previous, better path.
We’ve now explored every line from King's
Landing and didn’t find Winterfell, so we
move on.
The next lowest cost node is Riverrun, at
10 weeks.
First we check the path to The Trident, which
has a total cost of 10 plus 2, or 12.
That’s slightly better than the previous
path we found, which had a cost of 13, so
we update the path and cost to The Trident.
There is also a line from Riverrun to Pyke
with a cost of 3.
10 plus 3 is 13, which beats the previous
cost of 14, and so we update Pyke's path and
cost as well.
That’s all paths from Riverrun checked...
so... you guessed it, Dijkstra's algorithm
loops again.
The node with the next lowest cost is The
Trident and the only line from The Trident
that we haven’t checked is a path to Winterfell!
It has a cost of 10, plus we need to add in
the cost of 12 it takes to get to The Trident,
for a grand total cost of 22.
We check our last path, from Pyke to Winterfell,
which sums to 31.
Now we know the lowest total cost, and also
the fastest route for the army to get there,
which avoids King’s Landing!
Dijkstra's original algorithm, conceived in
1956, had a complexity of the number of nodes
in the graph squared.
And squared, as we already discussed, is never
great, because it means the algorithm can’t
scale to big problems - like the entire road
map of the United States.
Fortunately, Dijkstra's algorithm was improved
a few years later to take the number of nodes
in the graph, times the log of the number
of nodes, PLUS the number of lines.
Although this looks more complicated, it’s
actually quite a bit faster.
Plugging in our example graph, with 6 cities
and 9 lines, proves it.
Our algorithm drops from 36 loops to around 14.
As with sorting, there are innumerable graph search algorithms, with different pros and cons.
Every time you use a service like Google Maps
to find directions, an algorithm much like
Dijkstra's is running on servers to figure
out the best route for you.
Algorithms are everywhere and the modern world
would not be possible without them.
We touched only the very tip of the algorithmic
iceberg in this episode, but a central part
of being a computer scientist is leveraging
existing algorithms and writing new ones when
needed, and I hope this little taste has intrigued
you to SEARCH further.
I’ll see you next week.